how should a reality show producer deal
with their editor reality show producers
and editors it's been a long-standing
sort of uneasy alliance in some cases
because editors very often feel that the
responsibility for the show lies with
them story producers sometimes feel the
shield lies with them and different
companies support the notion that the
editor is more important than the story
producer and others that the story
producer is more important than the
editor I think that everybody's on equal
footing because a great idea can come
from anywhere and if you've ever worked
on the show with me the way that I deal
with editors is I'll go into the room
I'll pass along whatever my rough string
out of the material is or if we're
really blazing ahead and we don't have
time for me to do a string out then I'll
give them the notes and say these are
the things that are most important to
accomplish in this scene this is what it
should look like this is the texture
this is what it should feel like and
then I leave and I wait for the editor
to have something to show me there are
other producers who will sit in the back
of the room on a laptop and eat their
lunch and call their friends and do
whatever it is editors hate that being
watched
drives them bananas it takes longer
because they're constantly stopping and
going back to show something to you
again and they really don't need you to
say can you back that up three frames
can you do this can you do this that's
what of notes passage is for later so I
would suggest to any story producer one
of the best things you can do and if you
want to build a relationship with an
editor is know how to give them
information to be available to them and
to get out of the way because what that
also does is it frees you up to work on
the material for them that's coming
after what you've just given them in
order to run a show efficiently you have
to always be a few steps ahead of your
editing staff and you can't me if you're
sitting behind them in the room you know
watching them make cuts and basically
operating them like a remote control
what if you have a tendency to
micromanage then how would you handle
that there are people who have a
tendency to micromanage some editors
don't mind so much and are a lot more
collaborative it's it's very rare to
have someone who says boy
I sure wish I could find somebody who
was just gonna loom over me every second
while I'm putting this together
micromanagers what they should realize
is that you're gonna blow deadlines if
you're not letting people move forward
at an appropriate pace I understand that
you may be responsible for a show I
understand that you know something may
be very important to you to be able to
get this done the way you see it or you
have the vision for the show but you've
got to allow people to run the ball a
little bit before you correct them
because it tends to create a little bit
of the animosity especially when you're
working with people who are already
established and accomplished and have
done well if you're micromanaging a team
that's fairly green I get it
but if you've got an editor that's been
working for 20 years and a story team
that's been working for 10 to 15 you
don't need to be double checking their
work before it even happens and you
shape excuse me
you say that writers should know how to
edit with avid or Final Cut Pro or Adobe
we've gotten to the point where even
since in just a few years since my book
has been out we've really moved towards
a thing where my story producers tend to
have access to an avid now as opposed to
using Pilate where or some of the other
review things that we used to use some
of the other software we would be able
to review the material and then create a
paper edit that we would then pass on to
the editors that they would assemble now
we're just on Avid's putting together
rough cuts of the scenes ourselves if
you want to be in reality television as
a story producer you absolutely must
have a basic working knowledge of avid
or Final Cut Pro at this stage of the
game because you will be asked to do
those string outs for the editors you'll
be asked to go through material to find
support content for those editors and if
you don't know how to use those you're
dead it's just another tool the
typewriter gave way to the computer and
the computer gave way to the avid
you